[Music]
in an era where Nicole Kitman accurately
predicted what opening weekends would
look like physical media is gone for
good and cable TV is on its last gasp
Hollywood made a chilling Discovery
streaming makes way less money than all
of that so
[Applause]
Panic we will not allow you to take away
our dignity
the year in entertainment
2023 it's been 63 years since writers
and actors went on strike at the same
time when Democrat Union Leader Ronald
Reagan resolved the crisis this year it
was allout war between creatives and
execs over who gets more deck chairs on
the Titanic where the minds behind
today's non-stop parade of Mile
entertaining streaming shows parades a
Non-Stop stream of mildly entertaining
protest signs until the studios caved on
better pay more jobs and protection
against AI but drew a hard line at
letting the public look at their
viewership numbers if anyone finds out
how many people watch buckus on peacock
this whole house of cards goes down yes
sir what the is a buck think the killing
joke was the worst thing to happen to
Batgirl then you haven't met David
zaslov he may not be the first bumbling
coward with an open contempt for film to
run a media company but he is one of the
worst at hiding it this isn't an A A
really an entertainment service it's a
functional product looting his own
company for Quick Cash pissing off the
best living filmmakers changing HBO Go
to HBO Max to just max the app that
gives equal billing to The Sopranos and
mil Manor and going on a killing spree
of finished films and series that proves
he would ask his own mother if it gave
him a tax break hey zag remember when DC
Comics and Warner Brothers were run by a
mob connected parking lot company they
maybe that's more your speed once again
it's up to Disney to save the day with a
new CEO the old CEO this year he's
overseen hits like the worst MCU
releases to date and the most
disappointing Disney projects but surely
all the stuff they got from their
acquisition of fox will make up for it
these were totally worth spending the
GDP of Panama on right I mean you can't
put a price tag on something like the
boogeyman can you you can uh-oh so while
we peer into the yawning void that
stretches out before scripted media
let's tie a new surround the Year by
rewarding its greatest achievements
before Elon Musk tortures enough monkeys
to stream it directly into our
brains first up it's the Chris Pratt
award for ubiquitous voiceover
achievement and the nominees are
Aquafina for playing Aquafina as a bird
again and the winner is the Wikipedia
for aquafina's upcoming film Wildwood
where she will be playing Aquafina as a
mother whose child is stolen by birds
don't run a foul of the bird Community
Aquafina you can't spell Aven without
aav got bird poop wind let's give out
this year's Haunted Mansion award for
the least subtle product placement
apparently she uh stopped off to get
some ice cream the little basket robins
and the award goes to air the movie
about Air Jordans nope wait wrong
envelope it's Tetris the movie about
making Tetris uh no wrong envelope again
it's flaming hot Cheetos that's just my
grocery list oh here it is it's
Blackberry the movie about the
Blackberry we just love products don't
we folks us product heads really got our
feel this year yum yum give me some now
the Nick Cage keep it on in the
background award for the celebrity who
made the most consistent but forgettable
streaming releases of the year and the
nominees are Eddie Murphy for you people
and Candy Cane Lane Chris Evans for
ghosted and pain Hustlers John Cena for
hid and strike vacation friends to and
freelance and the award goes to Nicholas
Cage who is in the retirement plan
butcher crossing the old way and
Sympathy for the Devil congrats Nick you
may have been in a real good movie this
year with dream scenario but don't let
that stop your accountants from saying
yes to every offer addressed to Nick
Cage Daddy needs another Dino
skull ooh this is a good one it's 2023
is best response to being called a nepo
baby sea Penn's actor son ER I don't
give a about that because I'm not
one of course you aren't Lenny Kravitz's
daughter Zoe it's completely normal for
people to be in the family business it's
literally where last names came from you
were a blacksmith if your family was
like the black family okay Jam Lee
Curtis daughter of two famous actors who
wrote uh I ain't read all that and the
winner is Haley Bieber who said I am one
and I embrace that I am now was that so
hard we just want them to admit they had
an advantage not put them into camps
yesh here's the mcconaissance award for
the actor with the biggest oance of the
year the Josh haret asson the Lacy
shabber asson the dermont morona son the
asai Moralis son the Michael sarason and
the winner is the Jamie Fox ass son not
just for they clone Tyrone and the
burial but most importantly not being
dead even though the internet said he
was and the internet is never
wrong finally the congressman George
Santos Award for best Cameo of the year
I'm so proud of you for coming out as a
furry the nominees are galado doe in
fast X galado doe in Shazam 2 galado doe
in The Flash and the winner is Bradley
Cooper and Dungeons and Dragons there
are no small parts only small actors and
Be Cops you got to be both in this Cameo
better luck next year gal Stars War
episode 23 the broke Rider strikes
back that's a wrap on 2023 see you in
2024 with more honest takes on whatever
Hollywood bothers to put out next year
and hey if the movies die out we can
always pivot to election coverage many
people that are you know major criminals
very few have had an honor of being
indicted for I'll tell you one couldn't
figure out how were going to for
president ran was nice enough to send
Air
Force helicopter one based on what we've
just been able to see and because we've
seen it or not doesn't mean it hasn't
happened never mind Hey screen junkies
is the trend of superhero movies coming
to an end we track the rise and
potential fall of the Spandex and
punching genre in an allnew episode of
BU the numbers click the Box on the
right to watch
now something festive for Christmas
chewing gum is really gross chewing gum
I hate the most you think you're so
great because you have boats this
comment was written by a real human not
a
chatbot